hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event
my name is Jonas Carla I'm chief
scientific officer at PacBio and I will
be presenting on precise DNA sequencing
and necessity for precision medicine
please feel free to submit questions
during my presentation and I will follow
up with you via email just a quick
disclaimer I would like to note that
Peck bio products are marketed and sold
only for research use purposes so it's
for researchers only and not for use in
diagnostic procedures my presentation
will have three parts I'll give a brief
introduction and followed by examples of
how Peck biotechnology can be used
towards advancing the goals of precision
medicine and then at the end as the
third topic I will talk about the new
sequel to system so in terms of a
motivation and how far we've come with
regard to precision medicine and where
the field is going
I'd like to cite two leading scientists
in the field and some of their recent
perspectives on the left you see a slide
that was presented by Jason Dory a
Howard Hughes Medical Investigator and
professor at the University of
Washington highlighting in the NHGRI
roadmap and vision meeting that happened
a few months ago that we've come a long
way with regard to next generation
sequencing revolutionizing medicine and
that's because of the low cost and the
very high throughput enabling to
sequence literally millions of samples
and his perspective of that this will
continue and even expand on the right on
his slide you can see that and he says
it's not unreasonable to think that you
could sequence 0.1% at least of all
living humans of the entire human
population so that's you know eight and
a half million people now and so this
can only be you know accomplished by the
combination of the low cost and the very
high throughput that is afforded by the
shorter e technologies which have over
the past decade really revolutionized
medicine and have really enable to for
us to think about
medicine and then he pointed out that in
addition to those advances that have
happened and will continue to expand
there are opportunities on the left he
has an opportunity for long wreaked
technology such as PacBio sequencing to
complement those efforts in generating a
much more limited number of high-quality
de novo human genome assemblies that are
the highest possible quality telomere to
telomere let's say for dozens of samples
and ethnicities which will serve as a
reference to help map the short reach
technologies and make those more useful
on the right you see an article from a
few years ago by you and Ashley who is
at Stanford University again
highlighting how powerful the NGS
technology has been in bringing about
precision medicine and where we are and
where we will continue to go and
pointing out opportunities again for
Peck biotechnology to complement these
NGS assays to focus on particular
regions in the genomes of their high
complexity regions that are perhaps more
difficult to resolve with the chaudhary
technologies and that's where there's a
complementary opportunity for long-range
sequencing technologies such as Peck bio
to help provide a more comprehensive
picture of a human genome and as you
know as many of you know with regard to
the technology it can there take
advantage of the combination of having
long reads high accuracy uniform
coverage with minimal by is relative to
the type of sequence that you're looking
at a single molecule resolution and I'll
talk about that in a little bit more
detail later how it is possible to get
both long and accurate single sequence
reads and the ability to provide
simultaneous epigenetic detection all of
those factors combined aiding in seeing
some regions that perhaps until now more
difficult to look at with the shorty
technologies and so
mentioned single-molecule resolution and
so before I go into the examples I want
to point out that with Peck
biotechnology there is now a really we
believe powerful mode of sequencing that
combines the long reads and the high
accuracy to generate what we call hi-fi
reads this is done by a process called
circular consensus sequencing so on the
upper right you see the standard
template molecule that is being
sequenced a double-stranded DNA molecule
and yellow and purple the two strands
two hairpin adapters are ligated to each
end of that molecule to be sequenced
which makes the DNA molecule
topologically circular and we call this
a smart Bell a primer and a polymerase
are bound and then the polymerase will
start sequencing opening up the
structure and keep going around this now
circular DNA molecule and so on the left
you see schematically that it is
possible with Peck biotechnology to
sequence the same DNA molecule multiple
times over and you get on the bottom you
see what we call sub reads which are
passes of the polymerase sequencing
either the forward strand in yellow or
the reverse strand in purple and then
you can wash out the random errors to
arrive at a consensus at a highly
accurate long read which we call a hi-fi
read and the utility of this I will
highlight in the in the following few
examples so I'd like to in the next part
of my talk I'll show a few examples for
this where these types of capabilities
have been used towards informing in the
research setting about certain parts of
the human genome the first example is in
the area of pharmacogenomics and so this
is due to the fact that people have
different responses to medications it's
actually quite a significant problem
it's estimated that about 10% of
hospitalized patients experience adverse
drug effects 3.5% of hospital admissions
are related to adverse drug reactions
and it's currently estimated to be the
fourth most leading cause of death in
the United States
and the reason for that is that the the
underlying reason has to do a lot of
genetics so people have different
responses to medications largely due to
their genetic background this is a
figure showing that for the phenotype
here in the second row which can be
which is defined as how rapidly the
particular patient or the person breaks
down a drug of medicine and people can
be the ultra-rapid metabolizers or
average or they can be poor metabolizers
which means the medicine will stay in
the body for much longer and the
distribution shows that there's a quite
a variety of responses and people and
the top row shows that this can be
linked to the genotype to the number of
active genes that you have the proteins
of which degrade those particular
medicines and so it's of great
importance to the doctors to know
whether a patient is an ultra-rapid
metabolizer and if he would give the
standard dose then the drug would be
broken down so rapidly that there would
be no health effects but even more
dangerously perhaps for poor metabolizer
if the doctor didn't know that that
person was a poor metabolizer that can
be potentially adverse effects and so to
highlight the utility of PacBio
sequencing to sequence and to understand
these genotypes that then ultimately eat
to the phenotypic variation Stuart Scott
who is at the Icahn School of Medicine
at Mount Sinai and also at semaphore
gave a presentation a little while ago
entitled amplicon smart sequencing
applications in human genetics
introducing one of those important genes
that's called sip 2d6
it metabolizes about a quarter of all
current Western medications but he also
shows in this slide that the genes are
very complex and it's challenging to do
this with current techniques because
they are neighboring pseudogenes the
gene is highly polymorphic meaning there
are many different alleles and many
different forms and variations of the
gene
Stocki nicely highlighted the
progression that has been made from when
he started this work in 2015 on the
first instrument ours too that he had
trying to span let's say a 5 or 6 kilo
base gene was still a bit of a challenge
whereas within 2018 with the sequel
system and the version 3.0 chemistry
sequencing chemistry you see on the
right with the blue that there's very
even coverage now that allows you to
fully sequence the 6000 base pair of
camp Lacan that represents the full
length 626 genes in high multiplex here
he multiplex 48 samples in one smart
cell and gets an average depth of
thousand three hundred volts away more
than you would ever need and he then
highlighted that there is a very high
accuracy and precision so the triplicate
variant haplotype concordance was 100%
this picture here on the bottom shows an
igv view of the entire 726 gene that's
about 6,000 bases in this view and you
see two blocks of rows the pink lines
are the forward strand reads the blue
lines are the reverse strand reads and
the two blocks delineate the two
haplotypes the two alleles so you have
one copy from the mother and one copy
from the father chromosome and the
vertical lines represent the variants
relative to the reference genome and so
you can see a couple of things you can
see how clean the data are so these
these reads are essentially perfect
because there are no colors in between
them and that's a power of the hi-fi
read the long and accurate read and the
second thing you can see is that it is
how easy it is to phase the variant
information so you can see in this
example all the vertical lines the
variants relative to the reference that
would present heterozygous snips are
phased together on one allele so all the
variants are coming from one of the
chromosomes let's say the mother
chromosome whereas the father chromosome
is fully component with the reference
and so doing this work in comparing it
to previously
genotyped samples here is 96 samples he
found that the peg buyer they are fully
concordant but not only that in addition
he found that for about 10 percent of
the samples he had to either revise or
discover completely novel variants and
SEP 26 deploy types for the sample that
he didn't know about before and to
stretch the technology a little bit he
looked at another pharmacogenomics
important gene that's 11,000 bases and
very similarly and here comparing the
PacBio
sequel and the version 3 chemistry you
can see again that all the variants are
very nicely called and phased and for
example here showing in addition a 25
base insertion that so not just snips
are being detected but also insertions
and deletions and you see all the reads
basically show that this is a 25 base
pair insertion that only is present on
one of the appetites the second example
that I'd like to highlight today is in
the area of bipolar disorder and
schizophrenia and this is a from a talk
recently given by Janet song works in
David Kingsley's lab at Stanford
University I should give an updated talk
just recently last month at the smart
Leiden conference and the Netherlands
looking at the utility of pec
biotechnology to help identify the
causes of this important disease you see
on the bottom it is a big problem
affects over 3 percent of individuals
worldwide and it's in the top 25 causes
of disability but bisa despite you know
many years of study and G was assays and
and so forth the causative variant of
this for this disease is still unknown
they then looked at I can't go into the
detail but the talk was actually
recorded and you can find it on our
website so if you want to know more
detail
they found a region for near calcium
Jenny intron of the calcium channel that
was highly variable and we're using
PacBio sequencing of initially 16
individuals identified that there was
this region that was a very
a variable and had a repeat variant so
by southern blots this was initially
identified and then resolved at the
sequence level with PacBio sequencing
and there were about 50 detected
variants on the 30 mm motif so this is
shown here in the in the publication
that came out since then so if you would
like to know more about that I refer you
to this paper and in this colorful
figure a that you see there each row is
a different patient and you can already
appreciate just by the variety of the
coloring that there's a tremendous
amount of variation in this particular
tenem repeat region that was
characterized using paper a sequencing
and can be unequivocally resolved in
terms of the structure and the sequence
composition of this human calcium
channel gene that they're now looking at
further and she even update at the
Leiden meeting about the potential
significance as both enhancing or
repressing the effects that may lead to
bipolar disorder and schizophrenia there
was also press release on the right
entitled hidden DNA sequences tied to
schizophrenia and bipolar risk
highlighting how the pack biotechnology
can be complemented with the
high-throughput and cost-effective
chaudhary technologies to get a more
comprehensive view of genome the third
study is in the area of HLA and HLA
typing there was a recent paper that I
was very excited to see by Anthony Nolan
and by the enthymeme Nolan Institute
Steve Marsh and nima Mayer on the right
leading on this work providing a high
resolution HLA typing and associating it
in a retrospective study with the
patient survival rates so they show
these very dramatic kaplan-meier plots
showing that when you actually match the
patients with regard to the HLA match
again this was a retrospective study
there is a very significant
increase in the overall five-year
survival rate compared to thinking that
you had matched them but then with
full-length HLA gene sequencing showing
that this was actually not the case and
then finally in the area of going from
targeted sequencing to having a look at
the entire human genome we collaborated
with as you can see on the right here
are a large number of bioinformatics
experts in the community and posted a
preprint a few months ago looking at the
utility of the CCS reads to in inquire
on the whole genome scale about some of
those regions if you want details I
refer you to the preprint which is
publicly available but very briefly we
looked at one of the best studied and
characterized genome in the bottle
benchmark samples and the reason for
that was to evaluate how well we did
relative to what is best known as the
biological truth and the CCS reads were
able to then improve on the benchmark
data call set of the genome in the
bottle initiative again 626 is shown on
the on the left here phasing and
resolving the haplotypes unequivocally
and overall a an estimated 2,400
benchmark mistakes were corrected the
benchmark was expanded by about 150,000
variants and significantly in view of
the topic today for precision medicine
adding about five percent more variants
in what's considered the the medical
exome and so just to highlight that a
little bit more one of the figures in
the paper shows that there are a number
of genes and they're listed here and
characterized previously by Birgit Foca
and and colleagues in this paper on the
upper right that because of the presence
of pseudogenes and highly homologous
regions all those genes are very
difficult to resolve completely of the
shorter e technologies but our analysis
indicates from this paper that the large
majority of those genes are now
accessible through the long and accurate
pick bio Reed sequencing even some
the most difficult regions like the smn1
smn2 jeans are near reach these are very
extremely homologous regions pseudogenes
that have very high percent identity and
now with the hi-fi reads they're coming
and reached being even those types of
regions being resolved so then at the in
the last few minutes I then would like
to just give a an update on the latest
capabilities that aid these types of
examples and more for helping fulfill
the the goals of precision medicine and
the sequel to system you know in the
context of how epic bio the technology
has evolved this is a slide showing the
throughput evolution over the commercial
lifetime of the company so about six or
seven years we have built on the
foundation of the high quality that I
mentioned in the beginning of having
long reads having high accuracy minimal
bias we have been able to then build out
that foundation with regard to
throughput increasing the overall
throughput by well over ten thousand
fold by now with the introduction of the
sequel to system increasing the average
read length but over a hundred fold and
so forth so then in April of this year
we launched the sequel to system which
has a smart cell a chip that has an
eight fold higher feature size so that
translates directly to an about eight
fold increase in the overall yield of
sequencing and this is what we call the
smart cell ATM and what that translates
to is the same kind of performance
equivalent performance with regard to
read length accuracy lack of bias and so
forth but now with the higher throughput
translating to reduce reduce project
times and lower cost and so forth and so
how the hi-fi reads now look in the
context of the sequel to system I showed
this slide before this is a
representative example of the yield that
you get so you can see that for these
types of amplicons and medium range so
maybe up to 20 KB DNA inserts the read
length distribution has completely
shifted to the right where most of the
reads are now in very long reads half of
the reads in this particular example are
[Music]
you know well beyond a hundred thousand
bases and in fact for this particular
example the overall throughput was 320
gigabytes half of the data was in reads
that were greater than 167 kilobases
about four million reads so overall the
raw throughput of the system is up to
400 Giga bases the average read length
up to 100 kilobases and so then how many
passes do you need on the sequel to
system to get to a hi-fi read so this is
shown in this graph and we actually made
some improvements but in this regard
relative to the previous sequel system
so now it takes only about three passes
to get to cue 20 or 99% accurate reads
and it takes about 8 passes to get to
cue 30 or 99.9% accurate reads so that
in the end then you end up with
depending on the insert size and the
particular experimental design you get
between 1 and maybe 3 million of HiFi
reads highly accurate cue 20 or greater
CCS reads the redistribution of CCS
reads is shown on the right so in this
particular example the average insert
size was 12,000 bases so it translates
to about 12 giga bases of high five
reads about 1.9 million bases altogether
and the average single read single read
accuracy now is 99.8% but you can see
that the mode of the distribution is
actually much closer to cue 40 so that's
actually 99.99% and the same minimal GC
percent and sequence context bias holds
as you've known for the pec
biotechnology over the years so this
we've just launched a system and is
coming online and the first service
providers are now providing service at
hudson alpha at mount sinai and at the
university
Maryland there is a recent preprint and
that I want to point your attention to
if you want to learn more about high
fidelity long reads from the sequel to
system in collaboration of Evan Eichler
also Howard Hughes Medical Investigator
at the University of Washington
comparing both with regard to variant
calling as well as de novo assembly the
HiFi of the new hyper approach comparing
it to the more traditional continuous
long read or CLR approach looking at
specific regions of the genome such as
segmental duplications or Paris and Rome
Eric regions and I like to encourage you
to check out this new preprint if you're
interested in more detail so with that
I'll close but and thank you for your
attention and I want to close by
pointing you to a recent webinar that
happened last week and where three early
access equal to users describe their
experiences with the new sequel to
system and the recording is now
available on our website at Appy I see
be calm avoid slash videos and so if
you're interested I invite you to take a
look at that and how the researchers
have applied the sequel to system for
their particular research interests
including the topic that was the topic
today precision medicine but also going
far beyond that so with that I'd like to
close thank you for your attention and
as I said before if you have any
questions please reach out through the
questions and then I will answer you by
email thank you and have a good day